a weather disaster in texas is gaining
new urgency with many people still
just fighting to survive in their own
homes there are still
widespread power outages for a fourth
day in a row
though it has been restored in many
areas the food supply is also a problem
it's disrupted in parts of the state
causing scarcity at some food banks
and grocery stores and now nearly a
quarter of texans
are under boil water advisories because
the treatment plants are down too
meanwhile freezing temperatures continue
to burst pipes across the state flooding
homes and
businesses including this golf shop
outside of dallas we have a team of
correspondents this morning covering all
of it and we begin with janet chamleon
who is in houston for us janet good
morning to you
anthony good morning it has been a
challenge to find the basics
gas groceries in the hard-hit areas over
the past few days
this is one of the service stations that
came back online overnight
but hundreds of thousands of texans are
waking up this morning to day
four of the misery without power without
electricity without heat amid these
bitter cold temperatures
in texas it's a full-on humanitarian
crisis
this is worse than harvey and we lost
everything
some desperate families using outdoor
grills inside
and running cars in garages to stay warm
those choices
contributing to at least 300 cases of
carbon monoxide poisoning
in houston's harris county according to
the houston chronicle
i recall and now we got to deal with
this this man
now homeless after seven townhomes went
up in flames southwest of dallas
during rolling blackouts pretty short on
supplies especially
water right now with temperatures below
freezing an
hour long wait just to get into this
grocery store
inside some shelves bear and at this
market
customers waited in the dark
the dandridge family has been without
heat and lights with their 13 month old
son bobby
all of our camping gear has really been
what i've been able to use
and then i've been boiling uh pots of
water that's
you know it's kind of steamy in here
kind of survivalist trevor llewellyn's
been trying to fix his grandmother's
burst pipe
flooding the yard in freezing rain we
can't get it unstuck so
this water is just coming out and our
water bill is probably going to be
outrageous over there
and this morning no end in sight we're
hearing from families
all over the county this is
unprecedented
they're dealing not only with water with
power with no heat
what would you say to them right now i
don't want to raise false hope
and pretend that things are gonna get
meaningfully
better very soon so this could go on for
days i believe it could
because they still haven't gotten
additional generation online
every hour that passes things are
getting worse as texans wait for a thaw
and power to their homes
senator ted cruz is facing backlash
after an alleged fellow passenger
tweeted out this photo
appearing to show crews on a flight to
cancun
and looking ahead to the next few days
as the power is restored the issue here
is now water
dozens of cities are seeing taps run dry
because pipes have burst here in houston
methodist hospital had to cancel all
but the most critical of surgeries
yesterday
because they had low water pressure they
may have to do the same thing today
anthony janet thank you